one of my job's is to keep track of all
the disinformation that's out there
about health insurance reform thanks
Linda on Tuesday August fourth at 654 am
in a post entitled facts are stubborn
things the official White House blog
warned that quote scary chain emails and
videos are starting to percolate on the
Internet breathlessly claiming to
uncover the truth about the president's
health insurance reform positions close
quote so the White House needs your help
America in that very same blog post they
wrote quote if you get an email or see
something on the web about health
insurance reform that seems fishy send
it to flag at whitehouse.gov close quote
some might think that seems a bit big
brothers but not us and not now the
government takeover of health care is
too important we decided to take matters
into our own hands and help the White
House find these criminals first target
Peter Suderman associate editor at
Reason magazine listen to Linda describe
Peter there are people out there with a
computer and a lot of free time Peter so
smug with his little hat and his CBO
citations we'll get to the bottom of
this Peter are you responsible for
spreading lies and misinformation about
the Obama administration's health care
plan I don't think so nice try sudirman
you're lying through your teeth you tool
I mean I've repeated what the
Congressional Budget Office has said
sudirman gimme a break it's people like
you and the CBO who are taking Obama's
quotes out of context like when he said
if he could start from scratch that I
would probably go with a single-payer
system or that the people who always try
to scare people whenever you try to
bring them health insurance reform are
at it again that's right Peter you're at
it again it's not just that you have a
principled intellectual disagreement
about incompetent bureaucrats
controlling fifteen percent of the
economy through state-run health care or
that you write regularly about the fact
that more than eighty eight million
people could potentially lose their
private employer-based coverage it's
that you're using reliable sources data
from the CBO and cold hard facts to
scare people when making
arguments we'll see you on the flip side
Peter and don't do this in
you